let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud proud and do not
give a [ __ ]
[Music]
this is the tony michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the tony michaels podcast
and this is tony michaels
hey tony
[ __ ] him
[Music]
welcome everybody this is the tony
michaels and this is gabe sanchez and we
put together the best of the week from
the tony michaels podcast don't go
anywhere stay right here for the best of
the week
welcome back to the show thanks for
joining us we have a special guest with
us here today dakota adams a reoccurring
guest on the show as a matter of fact um
normally we talked to dakota about uh
proud boys oath keepers militia having
to do with january 6. but today i wanted
to bring him on to get his take because
he he has seen
this stuff before with the militias and
4chan 8chan some of these deep dark
parts of the web we know
now who the highland park shooter is um
he had a social media presence and an
online presence which i don't know if
that's a good or bad thing i hope
dakota's can kind of give us an idea
here of how that played into who they
are trying to make him in to be and out
to be uh dakota welcome thank you for
joining us uh for having a quick
conversation about this what did you
think when you when you um heard who the
highland park shooter was and when you
started to
you know dive into some of this
information about him who he was his
online presence what was your first
thoughts
well first of all in an ideal world we
would be able to shut down information
about these people because a serious
part of the problem
is
the
very fast easy pipeline of mass murderer
to
instant internet celebrity especially in
uh darker anonymous internet communities
and where we have uh mass shooters
inspired by each other's manifestos in a
chain and we saw that a lot with the
people inspired by dylan roof
unfortunately we don't live in a world
where
we can reasonably tamp down on these
people's five minutes of fame
and keep that from happening because we
have
in general a media punditry machine that
feeds off of any interesting information
about tragedies
and exaggerates it for click value and
then also we have political machines in
place
that will grab
any
noise they possibly can out of any
situation to deflect their side
from being blamed and that's what we
have here
and the thing that struck me first of
all
was that the right wing was going to
make immediate hay out of this guy's
basic physical appearance having
being skinny having facial piercings
having dyed blue hair in some of his
photos those are characteristics
that are possessed by people all over
the political spectrum but you know
that your great uncle on parlor is going
to run with that as a sure sign that
he's antifa from the beginning uh
wearing black clothes or having a black
face mask in any photo means that anyone
who does a bad thing is automatically an
antifa operative
and that was immediately going to be the
narrative that was seized but
really no matter what happened they were
going to seize the narrative of it being
a secret
leftist provocateur no matter what
and so the main striking things
about this case are the
history of violence threats of violence
uh flagged in school that resulted in
being in him being pulled out of school
the police showing up and seizing knives
and swords from his house after he
threatened to kill members of his family
and then immediately afterwards his uh
trumpster wannabe politician father
helped him
get a
go through the application for
purchasing firearms
like within months of the police seizing
knives from his home because he was
threatening to murder everyone so what
we have is a failure
in the family and familiarly uh someone
who should have been caught
in the red flag net that slipped past
because the system fundamentally is not
working
and
beyond that we see that this is again
he had previously attempted to break
into a synagogue and was turned away by
security in that same area which is
known for being a predominantly jewish
area
in this uh outlying community of chicago
and
that while not explicitly neo-nazi a lot
of the chat rooms he hung out with were
very racist
and that's where we have this larger
trend
of reactionary and accelerationist
thought that
is feeding into the background media
noise that is driving in my opinion a
lot of these shootings this idea that
western society is inherently broken
because or degenerate because
basic tenets of liberalism like
free speech democracy tolerance
especially tolerance for
the queer community or
minority ethnic groups is being
conflated
with everything that is wrong with the
neoliberal global order including loss
of jobs from outsourcing and
environmental degradation like it's just
a common thread
from extremist muslim groups to the
reactionary right wing is the conflation
of so-called
degenerate
social practices which is really just
basic human decency
with everything that is wrong with the
world economic order and how it has
disadvantaged the poor and the middle
class
and so you have this general sense of
this vague straw man of
liberalism and secularism
and tolerance catching blame for
everything that is wrong with your life
that is making your life suck so you
don't have to claim responsibility
or do the research on figuring out what
harmful systems are actually causing
your life to suck
and in this you have a lot of people
that are just very much on the fringes
of society that are already prone to
violent ideation
that are prone to anti-social behavior
that see this larger internet community
where violence against society
is celebrated
because
anything that causes chaos and
accelerates the collapse of society is
inherently good because our current
society is inherently sick and evil and
it's going to draw people
who just
want to be celebrated for being an
edgelord and provides them fuel
for
violent thought and anti-social behavior
and shows them
uh mass shooters
especially racist mass shooters being
celebrated just for going against
the grain
and that i think is
the real story here and you also have
him being involved in a bunch of niche
internet communities being a sound cloud
rapper having a hyper pop album being
involved in what people are calling the
nazi cat boy um internet social circle
so you're going to have people dragging
furries into all into all this as if
it's relevant wait wait wait wait wait
wait you said internet cat boy internet
not t-cap but what what do you mean what
does that mean i don't know what that
means tell me what that means
so you have this interesting phenomenon
going which i call the social experiment
petri dish from hell
is this is this like a margaery taylor
green petri dish type thing or is this a
a
pea tree dish not a peach tree dish is
it man okay um it could be could be both
probably because a lot of people in it
have no idea what a petri dish is okay i
apparently don't because i misspell it
on twitter but the and this is something
that's been going on for a long time is
that in the heyday of early anonymous
internet communities when 4chan culture
began to coalesce and form
these places were a catch-all for
everyone who did not fit into mainstream
society and that meant lots of people
with french political views
uh people
espousing racist views from the safety
of anonymity before that was allowed in
the mainstream
and it meant a lot of queer youth and
gender non-conforming people who were
trans or non-binary or simply express
themselves differently in a time when
there was no mainstreamed
or even
semi-well-known uh subculture for them
to participate in all in the same
melting pot
and then that melting pot of young
people especially young men
who were
on the fringes of society and felt like
outcasts was deliberately targeted by
white supremacists and violent fascist
groups the for recruitment and to be
made into a pipeline the most famous
example is the now where very well known
um stormfront attempt that was highly
successful at taking over large chunks
of the different 4chan communities to
turn them into white supremacist
recruiting pipelines and in that
catch-all they got everyone who was on
the fringe so you had
the early forerunners of
people who are now
called femboys just
men who do not consider themselves
transsexual
who
just
enjoy
exhibiting
feminine personality or body language
traits and dressing in feminine clothing
because they feel it
fits who they are more and there's a
subculture for it but because of that
early exposure
through these melting pot online
communities to vicious very well
coordinated white supremacist pipelines
a lot of them were exposed to racist and
fascist ideologies where you have
nazi uh gender non-conforming and
cross-dressing communities that have
tremendous overlap with other
somewhat marginalized primarily online
subcultures like
furry communities it's kind of a
knock-on effect
of the attempted nazi takeover of the
punk scene from way back in the day
anywhere where you have a gathering of
generally anti-authoritarian
non-conformist outcasts
forming their own culture
nazis will see that try to co-opt it
and attempt to build up their brand
inside that community and this is no
different
and the follow-on to that is that people
are going to seize on
uh dressing in women's clothing and
wearing cat ears
and
having a cat girl profile picture for
your crappy hyper pop albums
and they're going to grab on to that
especially in media
because it's quirky and unusual and
interesting to the majority of
mainstream normie internet goers and
casual twitter consumers who are not
aware of any
of those subcultures
and they're going to seize onto that and
in doing so further
the
perception of
all of these niche communities as being
nazi adjacent and facilitate their
capture as nazi branding
when the real story should be
that
these young men who feel like they're
marginalized who have crap lives who
probably have very toxic abusive homes
judging by the number of people online
saying that his father was widely hated
and frequently kicked out of local bars
they are falling into internet
communities that celebrate mass violence
as an ultimate statement against society
and also propagate
racist and fascist ideology and imagery
and the subcultures that he was a part
of
in parallel to that are less important
than the widespread dragnet
of violent ideology that is meant to
grab all of these young men
who fall in that same category who fall
into
uh steve bannon's uh much
beloved target demographic of
rootless white males
and inspire them two acts of violence to
strike back against society and become
famous even if only in their internet
circles
that's the real problem but everyone's
going to fixate on the cat ear headband
and the women's clothing the media is
going to run with that and obfuscate the
real issue right so they're not going to
get to the heart of why why they're even
reporting on some of these issues like
they like they like they should be um
and that's why i wanted to have you on
because
when when this first started happening
me and gabe were texting back and forth
because i went to the social media to
try to see what who this was and what it
was i was actually trying to
grab some of the videos that he had
posted because my one thought was is oh
my god someone's gonna take these videos
and they're gonna turn them into
whatever they want and their because
these videos are going to be taken down
is what i thought like is youtube and
some of this other content and they're
going to make it into what they want and
start spreading around these deep dark
webs gabe sent me an actual screenshot
of 4chan i believe it was won the game
yeah yeah like he sent me a screenshot
of 4chan of of what was happening right
in real time and i was like holy actual
[ __ ] like they were already all over the
narratives that you're talking about
um and it's almost like
they turned on one of their own it
almost felt like that when you were
reading what they were saying about him
and then going to like uh his social
media and seeing some of the things he
had said some things he'd done like whoa
it almost feels like
they're saying he isn't one of us
anymore
and and then scapegoating all those
things that you're saying that list of
things that you're saying whether it's
the women's clothing these are the cat
ears um because you said that you said
um
so smartly the punk scene and how the
nazis took over the punk scene because
it's almost like tried to that's the
thing is it wasn't quite successful
because they got their asses kicked
which is a lesson we need to relearn in
this year of our lord 2022.
right well but i guess my my question is
is that what what
the real story that you're saying that
the media is not going to pay attention
to because i want to pay attention to it
is what can't what is there anything
that can be done to undo some of this on
online culture where where it is this
like you said dragnet where they just
try to rope in as many people as they
can to get them to listen to their
ideology right and they know that some
are going to believe it some aren't but
the ones that they rope in now they're
part of the the team as it were so is
there anything that anyone can do is it
is it paying attention to it is it
actually knowing that it exists because
i think that's the one thing i've had a
lot of hugely important right well i've
had a lot of normal trumpers you know
the guys
like the fat guys and the trump t-shirts
and the trump hats like this guy this
and and and the boots and the blue jeans
and you know their their bellies hanging
out and they're like this guy he got
colored hair he ain't the trump
supporter there's no way he's drunk you
know i've had those like in my twitter
comments and i guess
they're not they're even even trump
supporters are very unaware
that it's not about the color of
someone's hair or where they grew up or
or what body type they are if they have
tattoos on their face or not
um it really is about buying into right
wing authoritarian stuff and i think
even they're missing
why like the cuban on thing like you
said nazis try to grab onto this stuff
like they i believe they try to grab
onto this q anon thing and really run
with it that's why there's these these
really
deep-seated roots of white supremacy
inside the q and on whatever the hell it
is right you know because they grab from
a lot of theories but
tell us what can we do do we pay
attention do we just ignore it because i
don't think that's the answer but no
just ignoring it is not the answer if we
could do concerted media blackouts and
stop
at least as far as not making these
people famous right and stop people from
like because that's the fantasy if
you're a bitter edgy loner is
all these people go trawling through
your shitty drawings and your
terrible social media posts that never
got any likes while you were a nobody
and analyzing everything for meaning
like why did he do this what was his
ideology and that's
plays into the fantasy
but we
cannot stop that at least not right now
right
the best
foot forward short of that
would be to start shutting down right
wing media outlets that serve as the
entry point for the pipeline
that gets these kids into
like
environmental neo-nazism or great
replacement theory
where
i've seen people advocating for this and
i think it'd be a great tactic is
what the hell is that one guy's name
the town
for gun violence
no
the uh the guy who holds uh dnc funding
by the balls perpetually who's super
about assault soros
no actually the one who actually holds
dnc funding
uh bloomberg okay there you go oh right
yeah yeah yeah if we could get bloomberg
to help guarantee or some other of
these
liberal dark money billionaires that i
keep hearing about that seem to be
totally missing in action when anything
needs to get done
if they could guarantee get biden on the
phone because billionaires all have
presidential access we all know that
guarantee funding to the irs to
investigate the [ __ ] out of right-wing
media outlets for tax fraud
because i have no doubt that they've all
committed or at least the individual
pundits have you could probably shut
down
half of the right wing media ecosystem
in about two years
if you took a really hard look at their
taxes and had the resources to go after
offenders
because the main problem is that very
large media companies are i believe
knowingly
serving as entryways into
right-wing extremist pipelines that lead
into accelerationism this idea that
society is inherently corrupt and
anything that collapses it faster is
inherently good so that it can be
replaced it leads into the great
replacement theory and white identity
they are knowingly serving as the entry
points
into information ecosystems that serve
stochastic terrorism this the idea that
you broadcast violent rhetoric
and rhetoric that implies that violence
is the only solution until somebody
picks up a gun and then you the
broadcaster
sitting in your comfortable house with
your high salary are comfortably well
insulated from the actual actions of the
shooter you have plausible deniability
and you can continue to signal boost
them in the ideology that created them
as a mass shooter so that somebody else
does it again it's a
fire and forget memetic form of
inspiring terrorism and controlling
narratives through mass shootings
short of shutting down right wing media
outlets
everybody needs to check on
the isolated teenage boys in their lives
because i
had a pretty disturbing close brush with
white supremacist recruiting pipelines
when i was a youth i was uh
when between our sporadic fits and
starts training for the apocalypse i was
effectively a neckbeard and then one day
all of the 4chan communities that i
frequented were flooded with violent
interracial um porn
by posters
badly role-playing as globe and black
nationalists who were celebrating the
cultural victory of black men over the
white establishment
it was a transparent attempt to get
people to
knee-jerk into white identity
as
a
counter-reaction add an instinctive
swinging the other way and then sure
enough in the comments people started
posting like prototypical versions of
the
like those those uh edits of
world war ii nazi footage with little
dark age playing over the background
it's the
popular music edited over nazi
propaganda from the 40s saying no don't
give in to despair uh the death of the
white race to miscegenation isn't is uh
not inevitable you can't listen
to these
anti-white crowing voices and a ton of
people bought it even though it was the
most transparent thing in the world and
i think
my
lifelong training to see conspiracies in
every shadow actually helped me clock
that this was
a deliberately engineered
uh bait-and-switch recruiting tactic
by white supremacist groups organized on
stormfront which is exactly what it was
the chat logs leaked later
and
everyone whose teenage son was on 4chan
in that time was exposed
to violent white supremacist rhetoric
that was key to play on all of their
insecurities uh sexual societal
um your place in life your future as a
member of the middle class all play on
all these insecurities and then set up
a violent white supremacist ideology as
the natural counter answer
then after that
going against all my instincts
of not being a snitch and not playing
into the information state
if you have that guy in your high school
who constantly makes
the mass shooting threats and draws the
edgy pictures maybe you should make a
report just to establish paper trails
because the system is not in place
to
actually
address this right now it's the one
common sense gun control effort that
would
gun safety effort that would make
the most impact for preventing mass
shootings is never properly implemented
and constantly handicapped
and wherever you can establish the paper
trail
to so that if someone does pop off you
can say look at this
there were warning signs here are the
receipts
it puts more actionable pressure on
people
but honestly
it sort of feels like
all this
has a good chance of coming to nothing
the coming supreme court decision that
would allow state legislatures including
state legislatures that are
so thoroughly gerrymandered that there
is no chance of anyone but a republican
holding the state house
allowing those state legislatures to
overturn the results of presidential
election and submit the votes however
they decide that's coming up next year
in the supreme court will effectively
mean the end of competitive
uh national
elections in this country
and the very next republican white house
will do everything they can not only to
destroy the electoral system but to
encourage stochastic terrorism like
we're talking about here
against all dissidents
and anyone that is against them ron
desantis will absolutely if he gains the
white house do everything he can
to dismantle any attempt at
stopping
or
being aware of potential shooters
like the one
that
killed six people seven i believe now
yes yeah at highland park and injured 26
more
because it
is a time tested
strategy to simply allow
non-state violence by your supporters
against dissidents to cement your
control
the debt squads
that fired on protesters after pinochet
took power
were not officially aligned with the
government the debt squads that slit the
throats of
democracy liberal activists in turkey
during the military coup attempt
were not killed by state security all
that happened was state security had to
stand idly by
so what we're facing now is
this rising tide
of
so-called individual
[Music]
lone wolf attacks
and mass shooters these young men will
be drawn in that are being drawn into
these pipelines
it's happening because they don't see
anyone fighting for
a better future
that will fix the problems that are
affecting them in their lives
in a way that
they're aware of like the
the complete lack of action
by anyone except crazy right-wing
demagogues
at fixing
anything or advancing any kind of goal
is feeding into the idea that only this
will work only collapsing the system
will work and the people with the
histories of domestic violence and
murdering pets and threatening to shoot
at their school
will be the first to pick up their guns
because they're looking for an excuse to
lash out at society anyway and this
greater narrative driven
by the ongoing failure of our government
is simply feeding into that and so we
see now is this
environment of a failed
society being used to sweep up potential
mass shooters
and beta test the messaging for inciting
lethal violence against dissenters the
next time republicans control the
country
so what you're saying is is that if we
allow republicans to control our country
uh which maybe speak to the
pro-democracy message um that if uh
an actor and fascist actor like ron
desantis were to take power he would
turn the 4chan army against our
democracy i think is what you're saying
that's exactly what i'm saying and not
even the 4chan army just the guy in your
local gun store or who talks about
well right how we need to how we need to
kill people i guess if you would just
just label it um yeah i mean you even
you even touched on it earlier which you
know steve bannon using world of
warcraft and gamers to to penetrate
through and get them you know i mean he
even quoted in his book of saying you
know that he was able to figure out a
way to manipulate that he's like you can
activate that army you know he was it's
inspired by gamergate where he saw
the minute there was something to this
directionless
rootless
society-wide anger
at
all of the entitlements promised to the
white middle class
dissolving and falling through
once you have a target because initially
there were people like that youtuber
totalbiscuit who did video game reviews
who were actually talking about ethics
and games journalism because he'd
received
attempts by video game companies to
effectively bribe him to give good
reviews of their games and he's like so
i think like people should
disclose when they have relationships
with game developers or game reviewers
in the interests of transparency
and then that was immediately seized on
as a funnel to pour all of this rootless
anger at society
for failing to deliver on all the
promises implicit in american media and
steve bannon saw that and he went i need
a way to harness this energy and that
feeds directly into the cambridge
analytica scandal where every tool of
the modern information economy
was utilized to develop and refine the
perfect targeted advertising and
algorithm driven
instruments of delivery
for seizing on this online army turning
it into political action and eventually
into violence
and that is where if
the current gop gains power again
without a serious cleaning of house
all the violence that we are seeing will
have just been test runs for using the
media to incite
violence against anyone they disagree
with or against society in general so
that
local government
and the basic functioning of the nation
can collapse and they can assert
authority in a state of emergency in the
vacuum the entire gop playbook is about
destroying institutions
so they can say the institutions never
worked
and enforce their own private sector or
religious alternative under their
control
to fill the vacuum it's playing out
through everything from law enforcement
to education
this is no different
the more chaos the better because they
want to ride the wave
well thank you dakota for joining us and
please come back next week after the
hearing um there's going to be a hearing
and it sounds like the proud boys and
oath keepers may be a
main point
in this upcoming hearing next week so if
you would please join us next week and
we can talk more what we usually talk
about
which is the oath keepers and proud boys
but thanks for coming today and giving
us analysis of uh what the deep dark web
is creating uh where we see some of
these mass shooters um coming out of the
woodwork and not knowing where they come
from but we should know where they
possibly come from if we would just pay
attention a little bit more and know
what is at stake
and don't get
don't get distracted by quirky
subcultures focus on what's really at
stake which is
the funnel that all anti-social
disaffected young men can fall into
when a massive media machine
is aimed at directing them into violent
social circles
well thank you dakota for joining us
come back very soon my friend thank you
very much thanks for joining us we'll
see you soon my friend thank you for
having me on i think during the pandemic
there was very much this dunning-kruger
effect where everyone was like within
two weeks to a month knew everything
that they had to know about covet right
despite all the years of schooling and
experience in times that you've actually
been on the front line studying viruses
they said i'm the real epidemiologist
right i'm the person who knows that
it's
a hoax or it's made in a lab or it's no
worse than the flu right you know but
i'm curious like as an epidemiologist as
an actual epidemiologist as someone who
who knew this was going to be a serious
thing
you know how did we get to the state
that we're in right now this is a very
good question obviously this is a very
long pandemic and
this info miss info had played a very
large part of it
but also political
inaction
political expediency and um just
sometimes downright ostrich head in the
sand approach to coven
hoping that it would just go away i
think obviously we know that this info
and miss info is very powerful um
a lot of these messengers very viral
they can go around the world three times
before the truth has the chance to get
its boots on and debunking is almost
never as effective as their original
viral miss info
and
you know
hydroxychloroquine ivermectin so much of
this has wasted a lot of time they're
not proven treatments the proven
treatments have been drowned out by a
lot of this information
and you know the natural immunity
oh i have god gave me immune system for
a reason yeah well i remind people first
of all if they did not survive and a lot
of people didn't survive their first
wave
dead men tell no tales that they're not
here to say well no it's not enough
only those who were barely surviving and
recovered
are able to even barely say that
so i think in many ways
people just heard from their social
networks that oh it's just like the flu
and you know let's be honest a lot of
january february march early articles
the mainstream news said oh it's just
the flu you don't need to wear a mask
that was incredibly dangerous so
obviously this info was very dangerous
it got people killed um
but also just natural social network
effects of bad information
um
and complacency and even the mainstream
media early on you know played a role in
you know basically
allaying people's fears and oh don't
worry about this but clearly they were
all wrong
clearly this is really bad we have had
over a million
confirmed deaths recently and over a
million excess deaths in the u.s since
february
um and worldwide anywhere from 15
million to over 20 million 15 million
being close to the who estimate uh and
20 million being the economist estimate
of total deaths worldwide due to covet
this is this is not a lightweight
pandemic
this is absolutely serious and people
have completely ignored that with a wide
variety of of excuses from from like oh
he died uh you know uh
with covet instead of front covid
whenever we know that for the medical
records most people died
um from actually covid or the indirect
effects of covid
it's it's basically
the short-term complacency is very easy
it's very seductive it's very alluring
to believe that you know oh kids are
immune
and oh you know 19 kids dying not a big
deal whether it's gun violence or
kids are not supposed to die and all
together this is just
a huge huge reflection of our society
how fractured it is how the information
is siloed among those who want to
believe whatever they want to believe in
their little network and based on
whatever their political leaders or
pundits promote
um and of course the vaccine miss info
is is obviously the worst of all that
the red states that had the least
vaccination rates least boosted rates
have
way way more
um covet hospitalizations
and deaths than the counties and states
that have the most vaccinations
and uh i think there's blood on the
hands of a lot of those who spread that
vaccine and sinful there's blood on
hands for a lot of those who spread the
covet denialism covet minimization oh
covet is over message
kids are practically immune they have
blood on their hands
um and so many things have gone wrong
and even the cdc have
has not been the best
in you know recognizing breakthrough
infections how even though breakthroughs
rarely lead to death breakthroughs can
still trigger
outbreaks and complete new epidemic
clusters
but of course unless it happened in the
u.s like for example the providence town
4th of july cape cod outbreak last
last fourth of july unless that you know
it happened on u.s soil with u.s data oh
all the lessons of the delta variant um
you know basically
uh causing three to four million deaths
in india in the spring of last year oh
that doesn't matter that's not real it's
because it's not here those far away
that's india right it could never happen
here and of course delta baron happened
here and it caused hundreds of thousands
of deaths in the summer and early fall
um
you know i think complacency kills right
and and
this pandemic has teaches us that we
should always be precautious
taking the precautionary
approach saves lives and actually saves
the economy if you act early you can
actually save your economy
a way
better than when all hell breaks loose
and people are um you know entire
industries are disrupted
like airlines even delta airline who
fought so hard to reduce isolation and
fought against mass
you know they had to emit over
memorial day weekend
um
yeah we had a lot of cancellations due
to
a higher than expected covet absences
well no crap we've been warning about
that the same thing happened with
british airways and easyjet at heathrow
airport just a month ago in april no
crap the same thing would happen in
america no crap that if you minimize
ignore covet your own
workers
and you know own um operations will be
disrupted because you know
people have such a short-term mindset
they want
they want things to be back to normal
they don't see what's around the corner
they don't see the domino effect of
[ __ ] hitting the fan and all hell
breaking loose later on
you've been listening to the tony
michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events in political news no rules no
boundaries i think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow tony on social media at
the tony michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them
[Music]
murphy's meal born head ass speech